latest poll uh has come out Trump at 48%
uh Haley at 20% so Trump's got a 28%
lead 28 point lead over his next nearest
rival Haley at 20 over D santis at 16 is
pretty shocking I'm somewhat skeptical
of that that Haley is actually going to
outperform D santis in Iowa I guess it
could could happen uh V at 8% which is
considerably lower I still think pretty
good numbers for a guy that no one had
ever heard of a year ago I think he's
done a very good job in this camp
campaign and he's been able to not have
himself be totally marginalized like a
Andrew Yang type candidate or like a
even a Ron Paul type of candidate he's
he's avoided that he's he's a very sharp
guy he's very disciplined and he might
outperform even this poll ASA Hutchinson
still in it 1% I I didn't realize he was
still in the race but I guess he is and
then there's a guy named Binkley he
showed up on the poll I've never heard
of Binkley but Binkley is in it and who
knows maybe he'll outperform and get a
point and a half